j'ai une question parce que j'ai mon
père qui s'évade signer et jean-pierre
en même temps alors c'est la femme de
jean pierre pernaut voilà monsieur
pernaut et mon père huit jours après a
eu un zona et jean-pierre
malheureusement là depuis janvier ça va
être un super scoop pour vous mais non
ma fait qu'à la mini a baissé depuis
qu'il a eu ce vaccin donc et quand je
suis à l'hôpital et que je dis aux
médecins c'est quand même bizarre parce
qu'on ne trouve pas on fait tous les
examens possibles sur jean-pierre pour
trouver d'où ça vient c'est mimi avc on
ne le trouve pas et à l'hôpital jeux
d'écouté depuis café ce vaccin oui jours
après il a fait ça est ce qu'il ya un
rapport et un taux si tu me dis non non
non non surtout pas et je dis mais il
faudrait le dire le score pour mon père
le zona il faudrait le dire et aussi une
autre chose c'est que le jour où je me
suis fait vacciner le lendemain j'ai eu
le jericho vide ma fille le joie s'est
fait vacciner le lendemain à la hugo
vide
un truc non mais incroyable moi je suis
pour les vaccins parce que j'ai fait mes
trois vaccins je suis pas contre alger
je fais mes trois vaccins jean-pierre
été pour les vaccins aussi voila voila
on suit comme les petits moutons mais on
fait les vaccins mais pour continuer à
vivre mais là je trouve et les
infirmières aussi que j'ai rencontrés
quand je leur ai expliqué santiago c'est
marrant parce que nous quand on a fait
notre troisième dose aussi le lendemain
on a une copine est la seule infirmière
cas pas eu sa troisième dose elle elle
n'a pas elle n'a pas eu trop vide donc
là mon fils je veux voir parce que
aujourd'hui il faisait sa troisième dose
tom et ça m'inquiète un peu tous ces
choses d'abord il ya des choses pour
lequel il faut il faut il faut du temps
d'abord il faut que les passions aux
tombes parce que là toute manière entre
ceux qui n'y est une chose ceux qui ni
l'autre finit par avoir des difficultés
donc il faut un peu de temps pour
analyser ça voyez regarder pour le
lisseur la sclérose en plaques et de
l'hépatite b en france parce que jamais
été qu'une histoire française il a fallu
quelques années pour qu'on revienne
dessus moi ça mais c'est une histoire
qui me qui me touche particulièrement à
coeur parce que peu de temps après
j'étais chargé de mission au ministère
j'ai essayé de faire une une réunion
internationale et conseiller au
ministère une réunion internationale
pour remettre les choses à part pour
dire écoutez on peut pas avoir juste des
scléroses en plaques comme en france
avec des 25 tout le monde
à tence et immédiatement tous les gens
qui avaient été recrutés par le ministre
précédent avait expliqué jean françois
mattei que je faisais partie du lot
est-ce qu'il est sincère je pense qu'on
dirait plutôt le monde irait plus loin
vers son intérêt qu il vous faut l'aider
mais c'est vrai c'est fou c'est à dire
on n'a pas le droit de réfléchir on est
dans un camp ou dans un autre camp et
donc c'est tout notre monde sait ce que
je sais bien sûr si ce que vous dites
ici on est dans un camp ou dans l'autre
le professeur ou doses que vous venez
bien voulait dire on n'a pas encore
assez de recul nécessaire comme vous
avez parlé des vaccins avec la sclérose
en plaques donc aujourd'hui on peut pas
ça on a su après qu'il y avait rien à
voir entre ce que disaient les chiffres
kouchner et la sclérose en plaques mais
on va devoir attendre de nombreuses
années avant de savoir mine de rien il
ya des choses qu'on mettra longtemps à
prendre il y en a d'autres qui sont il
ya des événements rares ce qu'on arrive
bien à repérer c'est quand des
événements rares sont plus fréquents
après la vaccination parce que comme ils
sont rares et il attire l'attention la
stèle cas bien qu'il y avait beaucoup
qu'ils soient passés
à la trappe c'était le cas avec les
thrombose vasculaire chez les femmes
jeunes moi je leur ai très tôt averti
pour l'astra gêné cas ne fait pas de
vaccin chez les femmes le savez vous le
saviez très vite faut s'allier ça me
professeurs ont passé les syndicats
d'abord parce que on avait eu un cas
dans l'hôpital après j'ai dit j'ai été
accusé de faire une campagne contre la
vaccination chez les soignants mais j'ai
rien fait du tout c'est les soignants on
savait très bien qu'il y avait un
d'entre eux qui avait fait un accident
dès que vous dites un truc on vous
accuse maintenant oui oui mais j'avais
dit si on mord quelqu'un si on mord un
chien dans la timone c'est pas moi c'est
presque
un petit à petit on est presque là donc
il y a des moments où les choses sont
inaudibles mais ça par exemple les
myocardite ce n'est pas non plus très
très fréquent quand on voit des
myocardite c'est des choses qu'on
analyse par exemple y avait quelque
chose qui est assez troublant c'était au
moment de l'épisode de la chana le
vaccin h1n1 donné alors qu'on a et dont
on attendait tous qu'ils donnent des
paralysies qui s'appelle les syndromes
de guillain-barré ont donné ce qu'on
appelle les narcolepsie et les gens qui
s'en donnent au milieu de la journée
comme ça et c'est une maladie qui est
tellement
que c'est un finlandais qui a rapporté
ça veut tout de suite on a dit non mais
c'est vrai il ya quelque chose avec la
narcolepsie parce qu'il ya dix fois plus
que ce qu'on en voit d'habitude quoi
donc les événements rares de cette
nature là on les voit mais les accidents
vasculaires cérébraux jonas et les
choses qui sont fréquentes il faut faire
des tests statistiques avoir des groupes
de comparaison pour pouvoir comprendre
parce que là ils n'arrivent pas à
trouver d'où ça vient ils ont envoyé un
baiser and mail tous les examens
inimaginable il trouve que
malheureusement il ya beaucoup de ces
situations auxquelles on ne trouve pas
une explication qui la médecine c'est
pas une séance finie la situation